yeah the whole the whole time I'm dying
who opens for you on the road you take
people at different people I'm Jade
cattle prod ah sometimes lost do I bring
Candice Candice no I like bringing girls
yeah yeah because guys sometimes I bring
guys and then they try to like bury me I
want them to bury me I do I know what
you're saying
you're like Mencia in that way oh no I'm
not at all like headline 100% not
Russell is Carl in the only way that
you're like him just listen to what I
have to say okay but I'm using my own I
know that your right ear own jokes
you're an original comic and you're the
best I'm not saying that I just say in
this new only a different instant or
I'll get 30 not there's gotta be a comic
you're like Joe wrote in that way yeah
you know how men see alike but like they
like a ring they like to bring strong
openers because I don't know what it is
I I'm not that way I don't like bringing
shitty guys either I just like people
that are like I'll tell you why I
brought a guy out bombs mm-hmm
we were playing Caroline's and as he's
done you know the host goes up and I'm
you know we crossed paths and this guy
that I flew out there he looks at me
goes follow that what it did right in
that [ __ ] flew off [ __ ] you [ __ ] nut
you know and he's trying to challenge me
in that way and then in my head I'm like
yeah he was doing things up there that
was extra right so that I could struggle
and I don't hello how long ago was that
years ago that's why you don't worry Jo
koy anymore no it wasn't it wasn't him
but um you know who I had opening for me
in Utah appreciate this Fung how I love
him yeah I helped hide with me he is an
Asian guy with an accent but he doesn't
seem fo beard to me
and he is he's only here seven years he
is fresh off the boat yeah but he is one
of those raisins a great guy but he's
cool it's cool he's had something hip
about him he's a vet he's like a hipster
asian guy without being a hipster right
but he's also like more
Chinese mafia kind of Chinese not really
dark yeah I know I love all those well
it's good he's also you know a lot of
Asian comics that are younger will walk
up to me and go a miney moe
you know Trang I do tend to you know me
and they're like combative yeah I get
that too right like they want to show
that they've arrived they've done been
doing it for a bit and so they come up
like you watch out for me but trying is
I'm funnier than you well perform for
your friend [ __ ]
but Fung Shui is always like always
pointing the right yeah he kept facing
the side of the stage but he said that
was better for the exact the audience of
love it anyway
he is the type that comes up to me goes
hey dude I saw you in this thing it's so
respectful - yeah yeah I saw you in this
thing I want to learn to be like you
like he's in that way or that joke you
do I hope but one day I write a joke
that good without the Korean accent
whatever that that's what he sounds like
my best that's not a crack in chick
accent whatever the baby my best
[Music]